J, APL, the array languages, they're coming to C++. This is the first step. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 42, recorded on September 1st, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we start off by responding to some tweets, talk about working remotely, and then talk about inverse scans and inverse iota. But so this means that this is episode 42, pretty special episode. We should start off by reading some tweets because we've gotten a lot of tweets.
J 和 APL，这些数组语言，它们正在向 C++ 发展。这是第一步。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客，第 42 期，录制于 2021 年 9 月 1 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我的联合主持人是布莱斯（Bryce），我们首先回应了一些推文，谈论了远程工作，然后讨论了逆扫描（inverse scans）和逆 iota（inverse iota）。但这意味着这是第 42 期，非常特别的一期。我们应该从阅读一些推文开始，因为我们收到了很多推文。
Why is it a pretty special episode? Episode 42. Come on, man. Okay. You don't know the significance. You know the significance. I get the reference. I was just not sure if that's the direction you were going.
为什么说这是一期非常特殊的节目？第 42 期。拜托，老兄。好吧。你不知道这个梗的意义。你知道它的意义。我懂这个梗。我只是不确定这是否是你要讨论的方向。
But okay. Wow. Come on, man. You got to trade some of that decorator knowledge for like nerd swag uh um you also gotta sit a little closer to your mic you sound like you're in like the notre dame i i think that's just my my ceilings are very like i don't know that's gonna get better all right so feedback from feedback from listeners we're reading feedback because there's primarily one one thing i want to read, but we'll read out a bunch of things.
不过好吧。哇。拜托，老兄。你得用一部分装饰师的知识来换取一些书呆子的酷炫玩意儿，呃，嗯，你还得离麦克风近一点，听起来你好像在圣母院里，我，我，我觉得这只是我的，我的天花板非常，我不知道，这会变好的。好吧，那么来自听众的反馈，我们正在阅读反馈，因为主要有一件事我想读，但我们会读一堆事情。
So a few episodes ago, we were talking about creating a new acronym based on C++ companies because NVIDIA is not in the FANG acronym. So we were talking about... That's not the only reason that we dislike FANG. We were also like... We don't dislike Fang. I dislike Fang. I don't like that. I feel like it wasn't about NVIDIA. I was like, why is Netflix on there but Microsoft isn't?
所以在几期节目之前，我们讨论了根据 C++ 公司创建一个新的缩写词，因为 NVIDIA 不在 FANG 缩写中。所以我们当时在谈论……我们不喜欢 FANG 的原因不仅仅是这个。我们当时还觉得……我们并不讨厌 Fang。我讨厌 Fang。我不喜欢那样。我觉得这跟 NVIDIA 无关。我当时想，为什么 Netflix 在里面而微软不在？
But yeah, no offense to people who work at Netflix, but I don't understand why you're classified in the same league as those other companies. And I guess part of it is a number of those companies in Fang are platform companies. Google and Apple both have this huge developer ecosystem around them. That's not the case for Netflix. It is the case for Microsoft. So I just sort of find it... And I think also in many ways it is the case for Facebook too. There's an ecosystem around Facebook. But Netflix is a different type of tech company
但是，是的，无意冒犯在 Netflix 工作的人，但我并不明白为什么你们会被归类为跟那些其他公司同一个档次。我想部分原因在于 FANG 中的许多公司都是平台公司。谷歌和苹果周围都有一个巨大的开发者生态系统。Netflix 并非如此。微软则是这样。所以我只是觉得……而且我觉得在许多方面，Facebook 也是如此。Facebook 周围有一个生态系统。但 Netflix 是另一种类型的科技公司
and a different type of tech giant. And so I think that it's a little bit out of place for it to be in that group. It's like no offense to Netflix. It's a great company. Obviously, it produces a great product. I think it's a really cool place to work. But I think it's a different type of tech company than the rest. But anyways. I agree.
和另一种类型的科技巨头。所以我认为把它放在那个群体里有点格格不入。这就像是无意冒犯 Netflix。它是一家伟大的公司。显然，它产出了优秀的产品。我认为这是一个非常酷的工作场所。但我认为它跟其他公司是不同类型的科技公司。但无论如何。我同意。
I would venture a guess. If you had to name like the top five, I don't want to say paying, like salary paying. And then like Netflix is known for paying ridiculously well. Like their whole thing is that you don't even really need to, you don't even really need to like salary negotiate. They do a ton of like industry research on what top dollar is for their position. And then they pay that to you almost entirely in base compensation like they don't really have like a variable component because their philosophy is if you no longer like working there they don't want you sticking around because you've got like rsu's vesting which is like the complete opposite of like amazon which is their vesting schedule is like 5 15 40 40
我大胆猜测一下。如果你必须说出前五名，我不想说是支付，就像薪酬支付。然后 Netflix 以薪酬高得离谱而闻名。他们的全部理念就是你甚至不需要，你甚至真的不需要进行薪资谈判。他们会对他们的职位所对应的最高薪酬进行大量的行业研究。然后他们几乎完全以基本薪酬的形式把钱付给你，因为他们真的没有可变薪酬部分，因为他们的哲学是，如果你不再喜欢在那里工作，他们不希望你因为有什么 RSU（限制性股票单位）归属而赖着不走，这就完全跟亚马逊相反，亚马逊的归属计划是 5、15、40、40
which means 80 of their rs user paid out two years in the last two years of like a four-year stint but but like like out of that list of like well-known companies that like pay well that you just listed i think it's it's really hard to make that list and not include microsoft like like look i understand you don't include nvidia in that list because we're not in the same class as those companies, but I think it's really hard to talk about Apple, Google, Facebook, and not also talk about Microsoft. Yeah, that's true. I guess that is, so it's a bit of, you can make the argument for Netflix and then backronym it, right? Because you
这意味着他们 80% 的 RSU 在四年任期的最后两年才发放，但，但就像在刚才列出的那些薪酬优厚的知名公司名单中，我认为很难把微软排除在外——就像，我理解你把 NVIDIA 排除在那个名单之外，因为我们和那些公司不在同一个档次，但我认为在谈论苹果、谷歌、Facebook 时，很难不提到微软。是的，没错。我想确实如此，所以这有点像，你可以为 Netflix 争辩，然后把它弄成一个反向首字母缩略词，对吧？因为你
had A-A-F-G and and if you add m i think we already talked about this what do you get you get you get gampha or something like that yeah whereas if you if you if you what did this listener have to say oh so so we had said let's create our own acronym uh we were talking to sean so it was adobe netflix you wanted to include microsoft because they were left out of the the fang yeah and so we and said, well, what word could we go for? And I mentioned Maine, if we could find an, I,
有 A-A-F-G，如果你加上 M，我想我们已经讨论过这个了，你得到了什么？你得到了 GAMPHA 之类的东西，对吧？然而，如果你，如果你，这位听众说了什么？哦，所以，我们曾说过，让我们创建我们自己的缩写词，呃，我们当时在跟肖恩（Sean）交谈，所以是 Adobe、Netflix，你想把微软包括进去，因为他们被排挤在 FANG 之外了，对吧。所以我们，然后说，好吧，我们可以用什么词呢？我提到了 Maine，如果我们能找到一个，我，
a company that started with I. And so we had a, we had a, if I, I mispronounce any of these names, I, I profusely apologize, but Mahir,
一个以 I 开头的公司。所以我们有一个，我们有一个，如果我，我发错任何这些名字的音，我，我深表歉意，但是马希尔（Mahir），
uh, Vadya said, uh, which company starts with I inner voice, Intel, inner voice, Intel voice. Okay. We will let the listeners tell if any company starts with I? Inner voice, Intel. Inner voice, Intel. Voice, okay, we will let the listeners tell if any company starts with I. Funny that neither of us thought of Intel considering.
呃，瓦迪亚（Vadya）说，呃，哪家公司以 I 开头？Inner voice，Intel，Inner voice，Intel voice。好吧。我们会让听众来告诉我们是否有公司以 I 开头？Inner voice，Intel。Inner voice，Intel。Voice，好吧，我们会让听众来告诉我们是否有公司以 I 开头。有趣的是，考虑到这一点，我们俩谁也没想到 Intel。
Well, I thought of Intel, but I thought we said Intel. We did not. We couldn't come up with a company that started with I. So my question is, do I have to cut this whole part out of the episode? Because we're not really our rivals we're in a class of our own okay no no i like it i like it main microsoft adobe intel netflix. Netflix and video. And video. I would claim jet lag, but that's probably not going to hold up.
好吧，我想到了 Intel，但我以为我们说的是 Intel。我们没有。我们想不出一个以 I 开头的公司。所以我的问题是，我得把这一整段都从节目里剪掉吗？因为我们其实不是竞争对手，我们在另一个档次，好吧，不，不，我喜欢它，我喜欢它，MAINE：Microsoft、Adobe、Intel、Netflix。还有 Nvidia。Nvidia。我会宣称这是滞后（Jet Lag），但这可能站不住脚。
Eric Keane, right? He works at Intel. He's a class act. He's really great. And Jeff Hammond, he just came from Intel, and he's a super nice guy. Of the people that I know that have come from or are at intel they're they're lovely people so yeah yeah yeah no and i mean intel's intel's a cool like and you know one of the interesting things about that acronym is it doesn't name
埃里克·基恩（Eric Keane），对吧？他在 Intel 工作。他风度翩翩。他真的很棒。还有杰夫·哈蒙德（Jeff Hammond），他刚从 Intel 来，是个超级好人。在我认识的来自 Intel 或者正在 Intel 工作的人当中，他们都是可爱的人，所以，是的，是的，不，我的意思是 Intel 是个很酷的，你知道，关于那个首字母缩略词，有趣的一点是它没有列出
all of the big c++ orgs but it gets most of them. Intel's big and invested in C++. So is Adobe. It's a classic C++ shop, and so does NVIDIA. Outside of the FANG companies that also are, what would you name? Bloomberg, obviously. Yeah, yeah, we'd have to work Bloomberg in. Do we have to work Bloomberg in? All all right so do we need a new yeah because bloomberg bloomberg is one of the um bloomberg
所有大型 C++ 组织，但它涵盖了大部分。Intel 规模很大，并且在 C++ 上进行了投资。Adobe 也是。这是一个典型的 C++ 阵营，NVIDIA 也是。除了同样属于这一类的 FANG 公司，你还会提名谁？彭博社（Bloomberg），很明显。对，对，我们得把彭博社算进去。我们必须把彭博社算进去吗？好吧，所以我们需要一个新的，对，因为彭博社，彭博社是其中的，呃，彭博社
is one of the largest investors in the c++ community yeah um it's one thing that you know bloomberg doesn't really like if you look at if you look at um financial tech companies of which Bloomberg is, it would be wrong to classify Bloomberg as like an HFT company because that's not what they do. it's almost like market services, you know, data, information, you know, the stream of information about various markets. So like in some ways, they're sort of like a news, you know, or, but they're definitely like, you know, I think they fall under the guise of financial tech. But there are a few others that invest in the C++ community like Citadel, but by far the most present one is Bloomberg. I learned something interesting about Bloomberg because I was having dinner with one of my colleagues, Alistair, who works at Bloomberg. And he told me that at Bloomberg, they've got – so they're based in Manhattan. And until a few years ago, they didn't like remote work because they felt that you lost something,
是 C++ 社区最大的投资者之一，对吧，呃，有一件事，你知道彭博社其实不太喜欢——如果你看看，如果你看看，呃，金融科技公司，彭博社就是其中之一，把彭博社归类为高频交易（HFT）公司是错误的，因为这不是他们做的事情。它几乎就像市场服务，你知道，数据、信息，你知道，关于各种市场的海量信息。所以在某种程度上，他们有点像新闻，你知道，或者，但他们绝对是，你知道，我认为他们属于金融科技的范畴。但还有其他一些投资 C++ 社区的公司，比如城堡（Citadel），但到目前为止，最引人注目的还是彭博社。我了解到了关于彭博社的一个有趣的事情，因为我和我的同事阿斯泰尔（Alastair）一起吃晚餐，他在彭博社工作。他告诉我，在彭博社，他们有——所以他们总部在曼哈顿。直到几年前，他们还不太喜欢远程工作，因为他们觉得你失去了一些东西，
you lost some element of collaboration by not having everybody local. But they did this other thing, which is very interesting, which is they've got three or four different sites within the city. And every few years, your team and your org moves where your office space is, maybe within the same building, but also maybe you move from one of the offices in Manhattan to a different office. And this consistently happens every few years that everybody gets moved. And it's like important to them that everybody gets moved so that you don't get used to being in one place. And the idea is that like you move around, you move around where all the different teams are to so that every few years, hey, you're sitting next to a new group of people and you get exposed to a different part of the company. And then that way, like there's more chances for synergy.
如果不让每个人都在本地办公，你就会失去协作的一些要素。但他们做了另一件非常有趣的事情，那就是他们在市内有三四个不同的地点。每隔几年，你的团队和你的组织就会搬迁办公地点，可能在同一栋楼里，但也可能你从曼哈顿的一个办公室搬到另一个不同的办公室。这种情况每隔几年就会持续发生，所有人都要搬迁。这对外他们来说很重要，那就是每个人都要搬迁，这样你就不会习惯于呆在同一个地方。这个想法是，你四处搬迁，四处调整不同团队的位置，这样每隔几年，嘿，你就会坐在一个新的群体旁边，接触到公司不同的部门。这样一来，产生协同效应的机会就会更多。
And that it's something that becomes a regular part of the culture. So so once you like if you if your desk is going to be moved every year, you know, one, the company gets used to doing these moves into you, the employee get used to it. So it's not a big hassle. So I thought that was interesting yeah that is interesting i've never heard of anything like that um yeah other than sort of like open office or open concept where you don't really have a desk and you just float around yeah like i think that's quite different i think valve does that yeah i was at an insurance company before i was a dev that ended up doing that really but like when you think of like innovative um uh office seating practices you don't think of insurance companies yeah i mean the company that i'm i was referring to was manulife and they um
而且这成了一种日常文化的一部分。所以，一旦你，如果你的办公桌每年都要搬迁一次，你知道，第一，公司习惯了进行这些搬迁；第二，你，作为员工，也习惯了。所以这并不是什么大麻烦。所以我觉得这很有趣，是的，这很有趣，我从未听说过类似的事情，呃，是的，除了那种你没有固定办公桌、只是四处流动的开放式办公室或开放式概念，对吧，就像我觉得这相当不同，我想 Valve 就是这样的。是的，在我成为开发人员之前，我曾在一家保险公司工作，他们最终也这么做了，真的，但是当你想到创新的、呃，办公室座位实践时，你不会想到保险公司。是的，我的意思是，我刚才提到的那家公司是宏利金融（Manulife），他们，呃
they tried to they're trying to be, they developed, this was after I left, but I heard that they set up a team called Loft, which stood for the laboratory of forward thinking where they were trying to generate these really unique,
他们试图，他们正在努力，他们开发了——这是在我离开之后，但我听说他们成立了一个名为 Loft 的团队，代表前瞻性思维实验室（Laboratory of Forward Thinking），在那里他们试图创造这些真正独特的，
you know, insurance ideas and policies. So like, I think, I'm not sure if it was out of Manulife or they copied another company, but I definitely know that there's a policy in Canada through Manulife that you can get where you wear a Fitbit, and it keeps track. It's like an insurance company issued Fitbit. And it keeps track of like how active you are. And you can get like a reduced premium by doing exercise. And also, there's similar things for car insurance in Canada where you can get like little brake measurements to see like how much you're braking and, you know, sort of like how safe you're driving and whatnot.
你知道的，保险理念和政策。所以，我想，我不确定它是源自宏利金融还是他们模仿了另一家公司，但我绝对知道加拿大通过宏利金融有一项政策，你可以佩戴 Fitbit，它会追踪。这就像是保险公司发放的 Fitbit。它会追踪你的活跃程度。你可以通过锻炼来减少保费。此外，加拿大的汽车保险也有类似的规定，你可以获得一些小的刹车测量数据，看看你的刹车频率，你知道的，类似于你开车有多安全之类的。
And that affects your insurance premiums for vehicle insurance. So there's some neat ideas. This is a thing that's not as common these days. But I actually I was reminded of this because I was watching an episode of the TV show Mad Men. I've been watching a bunch of New York-based TV shows to get myself in the New York mood. And also, if we're being honest, Mad Men has a lot, a lot of the furniture in Mad Men is mid-century modern style, which is the style that I prefer. So I've been watching TV shows looking for decorator ideas. But there's one episode where one of the main characters is going to get his physical,
这会影响你的汽车保险保费。所以有一些很棒的点子。这在如今已经不太常见了。但我实际上，我想起这个是因为我在看电视剧《广告狂人》（Mad Men）的一集。我一直在看一堆以纽约为背景的电视剧，好让自己进入纽约的心情。而且，说实话，《广告狂人》里有很多，很多家具都是中世纪现代风格的，这是我更喜欢的风格。所以我一直在看电视剧寻找装饰灵感。但有一集里，其中一个主要角色要去体检，
and the doctor says, oh, like, you know, you're only in here because your insurance company is requiring it. And this, like, used to be a thing where, thing where for your life insurance or your health insurance, your insurance, and maybe it still is, but maybe it's just that people of our age don't have that requirement. But it might have used to be back in the day that your insurance company would require you to go get a physical
医生说，哦，你知道，你来这儿只是因为你的保险公司要求的。这，这以前是一回事，就是为了你的寿险或健康险，你的保险，也许现在还是这样，但也许只是我们这个年纪的人没有这种要求。但在过去，你的保险公司可能会要求你去体检，
every few years and then send them the results, presumably. I think today people would think of that as an invasion of their privacy. But I mean, maybe it's still a thing. Who knows? I think definitely it is for certain policies. You have to be, quote unquote, underwritten.
每隔几年体检一次，然后把结果寄给他们，大概是这样。我想今天的人们会认为这是对他们隐私的侵犯。但我的意思是，也许这仍然存在。谁知道呢？我想某些保单绝对是这样的。你必须接受，所谓的，核保。
Yeah. Well, let me ask you this. So you, when did you move back to Canada? 2019. Pre-pandemic, of course. Yeah, just a few months before the pandemic do you think and you were on a team that was a remote
好吧，让我问你这个。那么你，你是什么时候搬回加拿大的？2019 年。当然是在大流行之前。是的，就在大流行前几个月，你觉得——而且你当时在一个团队里，是一个远程
that was a remote first team by which I mean it was a team that was remote even before the pandemic the Rapids team at NVIDIA you think you'd ever want to go back to working in an office so the answer to that question is if I have to choose 100% remote or 100% in the office, I will always choose remote. The flexibility that you get and the time that you save from like not
优先的团队，我的意思是，甚至在大流行之前就是一个远程团队，NVIDIA 的 Rapids 团队，你觉得你还会想回到办公室工作吗？所以这个问题的答案是，如果我必须在 100% 远程或 100% 在办公室之间做出选择，我永远会选择远程。你获得的灵活性以及节省的时间——不用
having to commute, I think it outweighs the benefits of being in the office. I definitely miss being around people, like especially COVID times. I essentially live by myself. And I'm just isolated, except for when I socialize, which isn't often because it's still sort of pandemic-y. And so yeah, like if I had it my way, like there's an NVIDIA office, and I would probably go into the office for like two half days of a week when I had like meetings, and I just take my laptop with me. I wouldn't have a desk and I just sort of there's a space in the sort of like kitchen area where you can you can grab a place by a window. And so you get to see people, you get to whatever chat a bit because I definitely miss that like water cooler aspect.
通勤，我认为这超过了在办公室的好处。我绝对怀念和人们在一起的感觉，尤其是新冠疫情期间。我基本上独居。而且我很孤单，除了偶尔社交之外——这并不频繁，因为这仍然有点像在大流行期间。所以，是的，如果由我做主，NVIDIA 有一个办公室，我可能会一周去办公室两个半天，当我需要开会时，我就把笔记本电脑带上。我不会有固定的办公桌，我只会找个地方，在类似于厨房区域的空间里，你可以靠着窗户找个位子。这样你就能见到人，可以随便聊聊天，因为我真的很怀念那种饮水机旁的社交。
Like it's sort of hard to replicate that, especially when I've only met like four or five of the people that I work with in person. Yeah. But yeah, the convenience of like being able to make a sandwich or, you know, go for a quick run in the middle of the day, like when you're at work, the overhead of going to the gym or going for a run where you have to, then shower and bring extra clothes and blah, blah, blah, and all this stuff. It's just a the overhead of going to the gym or going for a run where you have to, you know, then shower and bring extra clothes and blah, blah, blah, and all this stuff.
这有点难以复制，尤其是当我只见过我共事的四五个人的真人时。是的。但是，是的，能够做个三明治，或者，你知道的，在一天当中去跑个步——在工作的时候，去健身房或跑步的开销，你必须淋浴、带额外的衣服，巴拉巴拉，所有这些东西，这简直就是去健身房或跑步的开销，你必须，你知道的，然后淋浴、带额外的衣服，巴拉巴拉，所有这一切。
It's just a headache. Yeah. See, it's interesting that you say that, that you would go in for meetings because pre pandemic, the days that I had all meetings might would the days that I like wanted to stay at home because at the NVIDIA headquarters is like an open office plan I can't have my meetings I can't take my meetings from from my desk well
这简直是个头疼的问题。是的。看，这就很有趣了，你说你会为了开会而去办公室，因为在大流行之前，我有很多会议的日子，反而是我想呆在家里的日子，因为在 NVIDIA 总部是一个开放式办公计划，我不能开会，我不能在我的办公桌旁开会，好吧，
there's a tolerance to how many meetings I could take from my desk before I would get you know glares from my co-workers and we need to go get a you know a meeting room so those are the days that i would almost prefer to be at at at at home and like i i used to think because i was a big believer in like you know that it was important to separate your work space from your living space for like work life balance because like i i have a tendency towards being a workaholic, so I thought I used to not have a desk at home. I used to try to never have a workspace at home so that I would have to go into the office when I wanted to work. I did that when I was at Lawrence Berkeley Lab. Also, when I was at Lawrence Berkeley Lab, I lived in this miserable little apartment that had like no AC and no ventilation. So you didn't want to be in there during the day anyways.
我能在办公桌旁开会的次数是有限度的，超过这个限度我就会招来同事们的白眼，我们需要去订一个会议室，所以那些日子我几乎更愿意呆在家里的。而且，我曾经认为——因为我坚信，把工作空间和生活空间分开对于工作与生活的平衡很重要，因为我有成为工作狂的倾向，所以我曾经不在家里放办公桌。我以前尽量不在家里设置工作空间，这样当我想工作时就不得不去办公室。我在劳伦斯伯克利实验室（Lawrence Berkeley Lab）工作时就这样做过。另外，当我在劳伦斯伯克利实验室时，我住在一个悲惨的小公寓里，没有空调，也没有通风。所以你白天无论如何都不想呆在那里。
But I... And same thing when I was in Santa Clara, when I was at NVIDIA headquarters, I lived in a smaller apartment that didn't have space for a home office or a desk that was really near headquarters with the thinking being, okay, if I want to work, I'll drive five minutes into the office and then the home space is the home space. And then at the start of the pandemic, I was like, well, I'll have to find them. I'll have to figure out how I can fit a small desk into this tiny apartment. But I don't think I would go back because no matter how short your commute is, at least for me, and I'm somebody who's, you know, had ADD my whole life, the fact that I had to get up, put on clothes, you know, pack a bag of all the stuff I would need for the day, you know, eat a meal, get in a car and drive any amount of distance.
而且……我在圣克拉拉、在 NVIDIA 总部时也是如此，我住在一个较小的公寓里，没有空间放置家庭办公室或离总部很近的办公桌，当时的想法是，好吧，如果我想工作，我只需开车 5 分钟去办公室，然后家里就是家里。然后在疫情刚开始时，我想，好吧，我得找找。我得弄清楚怎么在这个小公寓里塞进一张小桌子。但我想我不会回去了，因为不管你的通勤有多短，至少对我和我这样一个一生都有多动症的人来说，我不得不起床、穿衣、打包一天所需的所有东西、吃饭、上车并开任意距离的车，
Like those series of actions were a barrier for me to start working. And it was also a barrier for me to stop working. And that was actually the more problematic part, that if I was at the office, and I was sort of like at the end of my, you know, I'd run out of energy, but I like wasn't finished with my task. I couldn't decide to just go, you know what, I'm going to have dinner now, maybe I'll come back to this, you know, for 30 minutes after dinner. Or you know what, I'm just going to go take a lunch or I'm going to go watch, you know, something on Netflix for an hour. Now, I could do that middle thing of like, I could go like, you know, just sit at my desk and watch a video on YouTube at the office. But making that decision to return to the
这一系列动作对我来说就是开始工作的障碍。这也是我停止工作的障碍。这其实是更有问题的那部分，如果我在办公室，我差不多到了我精疲力竭的时候，但我还没有完成我的任务。我不能决定去，你知道的，我现在要去吃晚饭，也许晚饭后我会回来做 30 分钟。或者你知道的，我要去吃个午饭，或者我要去看一小时 Netflix 上的节目。现在，我可以做中间那件事，我可以去，你知道的，就坐在办公室的办公桌前看 YouTube 视频。但做出返回
living space was a thing that I would do once during the day. So it was like a big decision. It was like once I decided I'm going to go home and be at home for some period of time, then I have stopped working for the rest of the day. And for me, like the greatest thing about being working at home is that I can choose when I make those transitions. And it's not a commitment. So that makes it easier for me to start working and easier for me to stop working. And I think that that's actually led to me to have a better work-life balance than I previously had. You know, if I reach the end of my day or like a period where I feel like I need to stop,
生活空间的决定是我一天中只会做一次的事情。所以这是一个重大的决定。就像一旦我决定我要回家并在家里待上一段时间，那么我今天剩下的时间就已经停止工作了。对我来说，在家工作最棒的事情就是我可以选择什么时候进行这些转换。这不是一种承诺。这让我更容易开始工作，也更容易停止工作。我认为这实际上让我拥有了比以前更好的工作与生活平衡。你知道，如果我到了这一天的尾声，或者感觉需要停下来的时期，
you know, I'll just do it. Or if I just like, if it's the middle of the day and I'm not feeling like, you know, I'm just not feeling energy right now, maybe I'll just stop and I just like, if I'm, it's the middle of the day and I'm not feeling like, you know, I'm just not feeling energy right now. Maybe I'll just stop and I'll go, you know, start cooking dinner or something. Or, you know, go do some chores, some errands around the house. And then I can go return to work later. And it just, it just feels, it just like the ability to switch between those two things. It's just a much better fit for me. And I never would have guessed it for the pandemic. just like the ability to switch between those two things it's just a much better fit for me and i
你知道的，我就会停下来。或者如果我觉得，如果是大白天，我感觉不到，你知道，我就是没有精力，也许我就会停下来，然后去，你知道的，开始做晚饭什么的。或者，你知道的，去做一些家务，做一些家里的零碎差事。然后我晚些时候还可以回去工作。这感觉，这就像在两者之间切换的能力，对我来说实在太合适了。在大流行之前我永远不会猜到这一点。就像在两者之间切换的能力，对我来说实在太合适了，而且我
never would have guessed it for the pandemic yeah i would have to say that i don't think i ever it's it would be very rare if i ever sort of start my day and end my day within like a nine hour um like fixed window especially due to the fact that my compile time is like 40 plus minutes i'm i'm constantly like in the evenings, even when I'm quote unquote, not working, like just still iterating on something that I know if it's gonna take, you know, half an hour plus to compile, I'll be doing my own stuff. And I can still, I can still like make quote unquote, like three to four hours of progress, where I'm really only working for like less than an hour,
在大流行之前永远不会猜到这一点。是的，我不得不说，我不认为我曾经——如果我能在九小时左右的固定窗口内开始和结束一天，那将是非常罕见的，尤其是考虑到我的编译时间长达 40 多分钟，我经常在傍晚时分，甚至当我所谓的“不工作”时，还在对某些事情进行迭代，我知道如果这需要半小时以上的编译时间，我就会做我自己的事情。我仍然可以，我仍然可以取得大概三到四个小时的进展，而我真正工作的时间甚至不到一小时，
but that's going to take like, you know, half a day of compile time stuff. I've gotten to a point where the stuff that I'm doing, most of it is like strategy and planning. And so if I do have a task that involves me like compiling or like for me, it's maybe less the compile time it's more like building like getting ci results back i'm lucky in that now i'm at a place that i have a small enough portion of those tasks that i can always overlap them with something else but uh but my one of my ex-girlfriends got me a signed copy of the xkcd comic where it's showing two programmers
但这需要半天的编译时间。我已经到了这样一个地步：我所做的事情，大部分都是战略和规划。所以如果我有一个任务涉及编译——或者对我来说，可能与其说是编译时间，不如说是构建——比如获取 CI 结果。我很幸运，现在我所在的地方，这些任务所占的比例足够小，我总是可以把它们和别的任务重叠起来。但是，我的一个前女友送给我一张签名的 xkcd 漫画，上面画着两个程序员
fighting with wooden swords and um uh there's like their boss saying hey get back to work and one of them's like code's compiling and it says under it the number one legitimate excuse for programmers slacking off um yeah but yeah like like i I don't ever really work nine to five days, but, um, I have, I, I have days that are meeting days and I have days that are work days. And I try to like, I try to not have meetings on days where like, I want to get work done. Like I try to have all my meetings on Mondays and Wednesdays, but, um, it ends up where now I do have some on Tuesdays and Thursdays because I have some committee meetings on Tuesdays, um, and some other work meetings on Thursdays. Um, uh, but, uh, you know, like I might every now and then I have that rare, you know, Tuesday or Thursday where I have nothing to do
用木剑打架，旁边他们的老板说“嘿，回去工作”，其中一个人说“代码在编译”。下面写着：程序员偷懒的第一大正当借口。是的，但是，是的，就像我从来不真的过朝九晚五的生活，但是，我有开会的日子，也有工作的日子。我尽量不在我想专心工作的日子里安排会议。我尽量把所有的会议都安排在周一和周三，但是，结果现在我周二和周四也有一些会议，因为我周二有一些委员会会议，
and I can just say, Hey, from nine to five, I'm just going to work on this thing. And I usually like take like one break in the middle of the day. But, um, like for me, at least like when I, when I, when I have that rare, like chunk of like free time, like once I get started working on the thing, like I can just go and work on it for like, you know, a good chunk of a like chunk of like free time like once i get started working on the thing like i can just go and work on it for like you know a good chunk of a good chunk of eight hours um it's just like the getting started that's uh that's challenging and finding that time yeah there's a huge overhead uh contact switch contact switching yeah yep yeah all right so back to we went on a couple of huge tangents there um but we got we got one tweet read at least yes all right let's let's go back to another user um there was a couple tweets along
周四还有其他的工作会议。但是，你知道的，我可能偶尔会有那种罕见的周二或周四，我无事可做，我可以直说，嘿，从九点到五点，我只做这件事。我通常会在一天的中间休息一次。但是，对我来说，至少当我拥有那难得的几大块空闲时间时，一旦我开始做那件事，我就可以直接去做，比如，持续好几个小时，一大块空闲时间，一旦我开始做那件事，我就可以直接去做，比如，踏踏实实干上足足八个小时，呃，只是开始做那件事很有挑战性，而且要找到这段时间也是。是的，有巨大的开销，上下文切换，上下文切换，是的，没错。好吧，回到——我们刚才扯了几个巨大的题外话，但是我们至少读了一条推文，是的，好吧，让我们回到另一个用户，有几条推文沿着
the same line so sean post his uh car crash story um hopefully hopefully uh everyone has listened to that episode that's listening to this episode now if not find it in the show notes and sorry for the spoiler a couple of them said that uh feel like sean parent missed the this is from gregory thane uh feel like sean parent missed the punchline of his story drove apple's porsche too fast around a corner spun out smashed the rear end uh into a pole. That's a rotate. Which I thought was pretty funny. And yeah, John Mullins said the same thing.
相同的方向。肖恩（Sean）发布了他的车祸故事——希望，希望所有听这期节目的人都听过那期节目。如果没有，请在节目笔记中查找，剧透一下很抱歉。其中几个人说，感觉肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent）错过了他故事的笑点。这是格雷戈里·泰恩（Gregory Thane）说的：感觉肖恩·帕伦特错过了他故事的笑点。把苹果的保时捷开得太快过弯，打滑，车尾撞到了一根杆子上。那是一次旋转（rotate）。我觉得这挺搞笑的。是的，约翰·穆兰斯（John Mullins）也这么说了。
That's a rotate gone wrong. Oh, audience, I love you all. And then there's a couple different folks that have replied or retweeted saying that that's adp adsp has become one of their favorite podcasts so pedgman was one of those individuals so thanks and also uh we're getting to the top um well and and you're missing the one you know people are pointing out the new name for the podcast. Yeah, yeah. So that's the one we're getting to. So Sam McDonald on August 27th.
那是一次出错的旋转。哦，听众们，我爱你们所有人。然后还有几个不同的人回复或转发说 adp、adsp 已经成为他们最喜欢的播客之一。pedgman 就是其中之一，所以谢谢。而且，呃，我们正在走向——好吧，而且你漏掉了那个，你知道的，人们指出的播客的新名字。对，对。所以这就是我们要讲到的。萨姆·麦克唐纳（Sam McDonald）在 8 月 27 日。
And I retweeted this saying this is now officially the unofficial title of this podcast. It's probably the best backron name I've ever come across. And Sam tweeted, ah, always glad to see a new episode of ADSP, AKA a discussion with Sean parent, which is amazing. Cause,
我转发了这个，说这现在正式成为这个播客的非官方标题。这可能是我见过最好的缩写词了。萨姆发推文说：“啊，很高兴看到新一期的 ADSP，也就是 A Discussion with Sean Parent（与肖恩·帕伦特的讨论），太棒了。”因为，
uh, definitely we've had, uh, Sean on, I think we've interviewed him three times, but that's been split into like eight or nine episodes. Yeah. At least nine episodes. Yeah. And, um, and yeah yeah matt gobbult also tweeted out the other day that uh he's been
呃，绝对的，我们请过肖恩，我想我们采访过他三次，但这被拆分成了八九期节目。是的，至少九期节目。是的。而且，呃，是的，马特·戈布尔（Matt Goble）前几天也在推特上说，他一直在
catching up on the podcast and really enjoying it um and learning about things he didn't think he'd learn about like apl and matt for those of you that don't know also has his own podcast called two's compliment um which is definitely worth a listen. Oh snap. And I didn't even see this one. Um, another backer name. Actually,
补听这个播客，非常喜欢，而且了解到了一些他以为自己不会了解的东西，比如 APL。马特，对于那些不知道的人来说，他也有自己的播客叫《大加赞》（Two's Complement），非常值得一听。哦，天哪。我甚至没看到这个。呃，另一个反向首字母缩略词。事实上，
that's a scan podcast. That's not too bad. That's, uh, shared. That's from share the parens with your friends, which is an amusing, um, an amusing, uh, uh handle anyways yeah we were supposed to talk about um
那是一个扫描播客。那还算不错。那是，分享给你的朋友们的 paren（Share the Parens with your Friends），这是一个有趣的，一个有趣的，呃，句柄，无论如何，是的，我们本该谈论，呃，
we were supposed to talk about we were supposed to talk about something yeah yeah because i didn't get the memo i was so we're gonna have to save it till i'm not even sure because i it would have been nice if episode 42 was talking about this. But so while you were, you know, moving and packing and we weren't recording during August on my other podcast, Arraycast, I learned one day that APL and Jay have inverse scans. So, OK. Yeah. So I think you mentioned this to me somewhere and I expressed some confusion. I think you just saw the tweet and then you were like – you commented on it and were like, what's an inverse scan? And then you said, or is that an episode of ADSP? And I said, yeah, we'll wait. We'll wait to talk about it.
我们本该谈论，我们本该谈论某事，对，对，因为我没收到备忘录，所以我们得把它留到——我甚至不确定，因为如果在第 42 期节目里谈论这个就太好了。但就在你搬家、收拾行李、我们在 8 月份没有录音的时候，在我的另一个播客 Arraycast 上，有一天我了解到 APL 和 J 有逆扫描（inverse scans）。所以，好吧。是的，我想你在某处向我提到了这一点，我表达了一些困惑。我想你只是看到了那条推文，然后你就——你评论了它，说“什么是逆扫描？”然后你说，“还是那是 ADSP 的一期节目？”我说，“对，我们等等。我们稍后再谈。”
So explain this to me because I'm really – so like a scan is – If you want, you tell me what you think an inverse scan is and I'll tell you. Well, okay. Let me just talk through this. So to me, a scan is of the family of, you know, a reduction. It's where a reduction produces like one final result. A scan produces all these intermediate results. Really?
所以向我解释一下，因为我真的很——比如扫描是——如果你愿意，你告诉我你认为什么是逆扫描，然后我告诉你。好吧，好吧。让我来讲讲看。对，对我来说，扫描属于，你知道的，归约（reduction）家族。归约产生一个最终结果。扫描产生所有这些中间结果。真的吗？
You consider a scan a reduction? That's interesting. Not a reduction. I consider it of the family of a reduction because, you know, it produces all these partial sums. I think there are a lot of problems that you might solve with a reduction where a modified version of that that you might solve with a reduction where a modified version of that problem might be solved with a scan. Yeah, I think that they're very similar. And I think that they have a lot of similar properties in terms of like how they propagate information and in how they deal with things like commutativity and associativity? Yeah, I'm going to stick with that. I'm sticking with my claim here. So then the idea of an inverse scan immediately makes me ask, what would an inverse reduction be?
你认为扫描是归约？这很有趣。不是归约。我认为它属于归约家族，因为，你知道，它产生所有这些部分和。我认为有很多问题你可以用归约来解决，而这些问题的修改版本可以用扫描来解决。是的，我认为它们非常相似。我认为它们在信息的传播方式以及如何处理交换律和结合律等方面有很多相似的属性？是的，我坚持这个观点。我坚持我的说法。因此，逆扫描这个概念立刻让我联想到，什么是逆归约？
And I have no idea. But I mean, I guess I would think that an inverse reduction would mean information propagates the other way. A reduction produces one result from many. So maybe an inverse reduction would send one result out to many. But I don't know that that helps me at all guess what an inverse scan is well so here's a clue is that in apl and j i i believe inverse reductions are not possible at all okay and in fact there are certain inverse scans that are not possible only certain types of scans can be inverted so for actually i'll pause there until you unless if you want another hint and then if you want i can give you an example of a inverse scan that can be inverted or a scan that can be inverted
我毫无头绪。但我的意思是，我想逆归约意味着信息向另一个方向传播。归约由多个结果产生一个结果。所以也许逆归约会将一个结果发送给多个结果。但我不知道这对我猜测什么是逆扫描有什么帮助。好吧，这里有个线索，在 APL 和 J 中，我相信逆归约根本是不可能的。好吧，事实上，某些逆扫描是不可能的，只有某些类型的扫描可以求逆。所以实际上，我会在那儿停下来，除非你想要另一个提示，然后如果你愿意，我可以给你举一个可以求逆的逆扫描的例子，或者可以求逆的扫描的例子，
and a scan that cannot be inverted yeah give me yes yes you want you want those hints okay so a plus scan can be inverted but a max scan cannot what properties does Max have that Plus does not have? This is fun. Listeners can play along. Maybe this will be a longer episode. We'll go way past the 30-minute mark. What properties does Max have that Plus doesn't have? You should ask yourself what properties does the result of a max scan have versus a plus scan?
以及不能求逆的扫描。是的，给我，是的，是的，你想要这些提示，好吧。加法扫描（plus scan）可以求逆，但最大值扫描（max scan）不能。最大值有什么加法没有的属性？这很有趣。听众可以一起猜。也许这是一期更长的节目。我们会远远超过 30 分钟大关。最大值有什么加法没有的属性？你应该问自己，最大值扫描的结果与加法扫描的结果有什么区别？
Because both plus and max are both associative and commutative. Right, right. Property-wise, they're very similar. Does the result of it have? And here, I'll give you even another hint because this is i'm getting too excited sitting here tech technically the equivalent of an inverse scan exists as an algorithm in the c++ standard library is it like an adjacent is Is it adjacent difference? It is. Yeah.
因为加法和最大值都具有结合律和交换律。对，对。就属性而言，它们非常相似。它的结果有什么不同？这里，我再给你一个提示，因为我坐在这里太兴奋了，从技术上讲，逆扫描的等价物作为算法存在于 C++ 标准库中。它类似于相邻差分（adjacent difference）吗？是的。
Okay. I see where you're going with this. I think. Which is like the inverse of a scan is like an adjacent difference. So it's just like the localized values. All right. Tell me. Explain it to me. To stay in the C++-topia for a little bit, and this was first pointed out to me by Christabella when we were discussing whether or not adjacent difference was broken or not. Because I have for a long time maintained that adjacent difference
好吧。我明白你的意思了。我想。这就是扫描的逆运算就像相邻差分一样。所以它就像局部化值。好了。告诉我。向我解释一下。为了在 C++ 乌托邦里呆上一小会儿，这最早是克里斯塔贝拉（Christabella）向我指出的，当时我们正在讨论 adjacent_difference 是否坏掉了。因为我长期以来一直坚持认为 adjacent_difference
is broken because it returns you n elements and it copies the first element of the input range to be the first element of the output range. Listeners of this podcast have probably heard me say that like three or four times by now. Chris's take was that it's not broken because the desired behavior of adjacent difference was to be able to round trip with partial sum to get back the original input sequence. So if you partial sum on the values one, one, one, one, one, you'll get back one, two, three, four, five as the partial sum. And if you then take adjacent difference, you can round trip back to your initial input and so there's this right yeah i don't see i don't see how you would round trip if you were doing maxes exactly yeah so when you do a max scan um you cannot do the
坏掉了，因为它返回了 n 个元素，并将输入范围的第一个元素复制为输出范围的第一个元素。这个播客的听众到现在可能已经听我说过三四次了。克里斯的看法是它没有坏，因为 adjacent_difference 的期望行为是能够与 partial_sum 进行往返操作（round trip），以取回原始输入序列。所以如果你对值 1、1、1、1、1 执行 partial_sum，作为 partial_sum，你会得到 1、2、3、4、5。如果你接着采用 adjacent_difference，你可以往返回到你的初始输入，所以存在这种——对，是的，我不明白，如果你在做最大值时怎么能往返。完全正确。是的，所以当你做一个 max scan 时，你无法对其求逆，
inverse of that because you have you've lost information whenever you have sort of local minimums in between values. Whereas a plus scan inherently encodes every single piece of information in between like adjacent elements. Yeah. But there is, there is somehow that is in some way a property of max versus plus. I don't know how to,
因为你丢失了信息，每当你把局部最小值夹在值中间时。而 plus scan 本质上编码了像相邻元素之间的每一个信息。是的。但是，不知何故，这在某种程度上是 max 与 plus 的一个属性。我不知道怎么，
and you know what i i i will argue that there's probably there are i i assume when you said plus you meant plus on like integers as opposed to i don't know like plus on strings or some other uh well so if plus is defined as cat nation it would still work right if you had the characters or the strings a b c d e f g as all individual characters and then you did a what about what about on like floating point numbers because you're going to have information loss there i mean floating point is like there's always an asterisk next to that because of NANDs and stuff like that. But I mean, and precision and whatnot. But arguably, you can get back, you know, minus some precision and minus the corner cases of floating point. You can get back your results.
你知道吗，我敢说可能存在——我假设当你提到 plus 时，你指的是整数上的 plus，而不是像字符串上的 plus 或其他一些——好吧，如果 plus 被定义为拼接（concatenation），它仍然有效，对吧？如果你把字符或字符串 a b c d e f g 作为所有单独的字符，然后你做了一个——浮点数怎么样，因为你会在那里丢失信息？我的意思是，浮点数就像旁边总是有个星号，因为有 NaN 之类的东西。但我的意思是，还有精度等等。但可以说，你可以找回，你知道的，减去一些精度和浮点数的边界情况。你可以找回你的结果。
Here's another one. What about like a Boolean operator? That also would not work. So if you wanted to do like something something like an all of you know because you're going to lose information there too yeah if you well so all of is a reduction but if you did the equivalent like logical and uh scan and you had the sequence like zero one zero one zero one that'll return you zero one one one one one one to the end and you're only going to be able to find you know the one one one one one one to the end and you're only
这里还有另一个。布尔运算符怎么样？那也行不通。所以如果你想做类似 all_of 的事情，你知道的，因为你也会在那里丢失信息，是的，如果你——allOf 是一个归约，但如果你做等效的逻辑与扫描，并且你的序列是 0 1 0 1 0 1，它会返回 0 1 1 1 1 1 一直到结束，而你将只能找到，你知道的，第一个是 1 的元素，然后你就失去了所有信息。
going to be able to find you know the first element that was a one and then you've lost all information cs it has to basically your binary operation combined with the scan has to encode each of the values in the adjacent values and if your binary operation does not do that then it's not so so that property there must be a name for that property. I wonder if there's a mathematical or a name from CS theory for that property. I do not know if it exists.
所以基本上，你的二元运算与扫描相结合，必须在相邻值中编码每个值，如果你的二元运算没有做到这一点，那么它就不是——所以那个属性，那个属性一定有个名字。我想知道数学或计算机科学理论中是否有那个属性的名字。我不知道它是否存在。
And it's interesting because... Maybe one of our listeners will. I'm not sure it's so much a property of the binary operation as it is the resulting scan combined with the binary op. Because if you go 1 plus 2, as it is like the resulting scan combined with the binary op? Because like a plus, like if you go one plus two, you get three,
这很有趣，因为……也许我们的听众会知道。我不确定这更多是二元运算本身的属性，还是结果扫描与二元运算结合后的属性。因为如果你做 1 加 2，就像结果扫描结合二元运算那样？因为就像加法，比如你做 1 加 2，你得到 3，
but like just looking at the binary operation on its own, you've lost all information there, right? The same way if you have like one max two, you get back two, you've lost, was it two zero? You only know, you've lost information, but it's the combination of the scan with the binary operation.
但如果只看二元运算本身，你就在那里失去了所有的信息，对吧？同样地，如果你有像 1 max 2 这样的操作，你得到 2，你失去了，是 2 还是 0？你只知道，你失去了信息，但这是扫描与二元运算的结合。
Well, it's some property about whether there exists like this inverting operation where you can take, can you take two of the results that are next to each other and recover the original from it, right? Like, is there some operation that exists that you can take two of the partial sums and get back the original values right yeah yeah and i don't know what that so yeah i bet that there is i bet that there is some mathematical
嗯，这是关于是否存在某种求逆操作的属性，你可以拿相邻的两个结果并从中恢复出原始数据，对吧？比如，是否存在某种操作，你可以拿两个部分和并恢复出原始值？对啊，对啊，我不知道那是什么，所以，是的，我打赌一定存在某种数学
term uh that describes this well we've got got, I don't know how many, we get on average like a thousand listens an episode. Somebody will help us. If you're a math background, add us on Twitter. And if you don't have Twitter, you can find us on GitHub, on my GitHub repo, or just go to the website. Yeah, and that'll take you to the GitHub repo, and you can post us a note.
术语，呃，可以很好地描述这一点。我们每集平均大概有一千次收听。总会有人帮我们的。如果你有数学背景，在 Twitter 上加我们。如果你没有 Twitter，你可以在 GitHub 上找到我们，在我的 GitHub 仓库里，或者直接去网站。对，那会带你到 GitHub 仓库，你可以给我们留言。
I'd be very curious to know. So how different is an APL inverse scan from like a generalized adjacent difference? A generalized adjacent difference? So like on a plus scan, it's basically the exact same thing what i mean is like adjacent difference is not like it i believe it has like um it has like minus hard coded in etc well it's the default binary operation um yeah but yeah so like if you do an inverse plus scan on one two three four five you will get the exact same result. If you did an adjacent difference on one, two,
我非常好奇。那么，APL 的逆扫描和广义相邻差分有什么区别呢？广义相邻差分？所以在加法扫描上，它基本上是完全一样的。我的意思是，相邻差分不像，我相信它有，呃，它把减法硬编码在里面了等等。嗯，这是默认的二元运算。是的，但所以，如果你对 1 2 3 4 5 执行逆加法扫描，你会得到完全相同的结果。如果你对 1 2
three, four, five. Um, and it's funny because we also have a name for it, for the generalized adjacent difference. Uh, we're getting adjacent transform in ranges because that's a better name.
3 4 5 执行相邻差分。呃，这很有趣，因为我们对广义相邻差分也有一个名字。呃，我们在 ranges 中引入了 adjacent transform，因为这是一个更好的名字。
And that's the one with the N minus one behavior. But so, so, so is an inverse scan adjacent transform in c++ no um i mean an inverse scan is just the inverse of the the possible scan uh we right right but is the is the way that you would express that in c++ adjacent adjacent transform i would express it with adjacent difference because it actually it actually that right but that you can't always but that's only if it's a plus scan
这就是那个具有 N 减 1 行为的。但是，所以，所以逆扫描是 C++ 中的 adjacent transform 吗？不，呃，我的意思是，逆扫描只是可能的扫描的逆运算，我们……对，对，但这是你在 C++ 中表达它的方式吗？adjacent transform，我会用 adjacent difference 表达，因为它实际上，实际上，对，但你不能总是……但这仅限于加法扫描。
um it's only if the binary operation is quote unquote invertible for the lack of the word that we don't have for it but right but well but no no it's it's only if the uh hang on if if uh if the inversion operation is i don't know no there is an overload of adjacent difference it takes a binary operation yeah yeah okay yeah oh sorry yeah that's that's what i was like i was thinking yeah if you're doing multiple like a multiply scan, you can get the inverse by just overloading the... We only added the overload of adjacent difference that... No, it's been there. It's been there since C++. Yeah. And the whole other extension of this topic is that you get this inverse scan by doing,
呃，只有当二元运算是所谓的“可逆的”（我们找不到合适的词来形容它）时才是这样，但是，对，但是，不，不，这是只有当，呃，等等，如果，呃，如果求逆操作是……我不知道，不，adjacent difference 有一个重载，它接受一个二元运算，对，对，好吧，对，哦，抱歉，对，这就是我当时想的，对，如果你在做多次的，比如乘法扫描，你可以通过重载……我们只添加了 adjacent difference 的重载，它……不，它一直都在。从 C++ 开始就在了。对。这个话题的另一个延伸是，你通过这样做来获得这个逆扫描，
using the power operator in APL, which usually you use with a positive number. So if you want to perform some function two, three, four, five times, you go power two, but you can also go power negative one and that inverts it. And that works on a variety of different functions. So there's also explain, Oh, okay.'s also explain oh okay you apply the power you apply the power operator to the scan operator correct um and so then what happens what happens if you do a power two to a scan operator uh i believe it's going to scan twice do a plus scan twice so if you start with one one one one one you're going to get back 1, 2, 3, 4, 5. And then if you do that again,
在 APL 中使用幂运算符，通常你把它和一个正数一起使用。所以如果你想执行某个函数 2、3、4、5 次，你使用 power 2，但你也可以使用 power -1，这会将其求逆。这适用于各种不同的函数。所以还有解释，哦，好吧。还有解释，哦，好吧，你将幂运算符应用于扫描运算符，对吗？呃，然后会发生什么，如果你对扫描运算符执行 power 2 会发生什么？呃，我想它会扫描两次，执行两次加法扫描。所以如果你以 1 1 1 1 1 开始，你会得到
you're going to get back 1, 3, 6, 10, 15, 15. Yeah, is that right? Yeah, it's almost like a derivative. In fact, let's really quickly. It is kind of like a derivative. Do you want me to share my screen? Yeah, go for it. Users, I am now looking at a screen with a bunch of symbols so if we do
1, 2, 3, 4, 5。然后如果你再这样做一次，
quirky symbols if we do they look like egyptian hieroglyphs that's reduction so we got plus scan once and then if we uh do power two okay the power symbol is a little asterisk with two dots above it. It's called the diarisis. Diarisis? Yeah. Diarisis. Yeah. Because this is, it actually really makes a lot of sense. The power by itself, if you do two power five, you're going to get 32 because it's exponential. the the diorosis typically is used to denote an operator so it's basically like just a power operator it's exactly what it is and so yeah if you instead of if I go iota 5 back to iota 5 wait why did you not use iota in the previous example because we were we were
你会得到 1, 3, 6, 10, 15, 15。对，是这样吗？对，这有点像导数。事实上，我们快来看看。这确实有点像导数。你想让我分享我的屏幕吗？对，来吧。用户们，我现在正看着一个有一堆符号的屏幕，所以如果我们做
starting with uh we were starting with five ones initially so we went from five ones to one two three four five because of the plus scan to one three six ten fifteen because of the power two but if we want to do an inverse scan we have to start with iota 5 and then do a plus scan power negative 1, and this is going to give us back 5 1s. So you want to see some... Why couldn't we do that? I'm confused. Well, so if we did it with...
奇特的符号，如果我们做……它们看起来像埃及象形文字，那是归约，所以我们进行了一次加法扫描，然后如果我们呃做 power 2，好的，幂符号是一个上面有两个点的小星号。它被称为分音符（Diarisis）。分音符？对。分音符。对。因为这，这其实非常合理。幂本身，如果你做 2 幂 5，你会得到 32，因为它是指数运算。分音符通常用于表示一个运算符，所以它基本上就像一个幂运算符，它正是如此。所以，是的，如果你不，如果我回到 iota 5，回到 iota 5，等等，你为什么在之前的例子中没有使用 iota？因为我们是
Let's see how well you understand it. Say if we replace the iota 5, so instead of doing an inverse plus scan on iota five which is one two three four five we do it on five ones what are we going to get back do you know it's going to be like one zero zero zero zero look at that bryce there we go an apl expert so so here's here's the real fun what if we do iota inverse on one two three what's this gonna give us iota inverse um what is the inverse of an iota well wouldn't that be like a sequence of ones so remember it gives us back it basically gives it's like uh what did Adam from ArrayCast and Dialogue, he explained it as sort of Jeopardy, you know? It's what gives us the sequence 1, 2, 3 when passed to IOTA?
以 5 个 1 开始的，所以我们从 5 个 1 通过加法扫描变成了 1 2 3 4 5，通过 power 2 变成了 1 3 6 10 15。但如果我们想做一个逆扫描，我们必须从 iota 5 开始，然后做一个加法扫描 power -1，这将给我们返回 5 个 1。所以你想看一些……为什么我们不能那样做？我很困惑。好吧，所以如果我们用……
Well, IOTA, I don't think of it, IOTA is taking, I think of it, IOTA is generating the sequence 1, 2, 3. But what do you have to pass to it in order to get it to generate that? Oh, like three? Exactly. Oh, interesting. So APL's got inverse scans. It's got inverse iota. Yeah.
让我们看看你理解得有多好。比方说，如果我们替换 iota 5，所以我们不对 iota 5（也就是 1 2 3 4 5）执行逆加法扫描，而是对 5 个 1 执行，我们会得到什么？你知道吗？它会像 1 0 0 0 0。看那个，布莱斯，我们找到了，一个 APL 专家！所以，所以，这里有个真正有趣的问题，如果我们对 1 2 3 执行 iota 逆运算，这会给我们什么？iota 逆运算……iota 的逆运算是什么？那不就是一串 1 吗？所以记住，它返回给我们，它基本上给出的就像是……来自 ArrayCast 和 Dialogue 的亚当是怎么解释的？有点像《危险边缘》（Jeopardy）节目，你知道吗？是什么传给 IOTA 后得到了序列 1, 2, 3？
But it's interesting. It gives you a scalar result. I guess that makes sense. I mean, it seems like a pretty useless um algorithm to me like what's what are you going to use an inverse iota for other than to check maybe that you have a monotonically increasing sequence that starts at one what happens what happens if you gave it if you gave one two four two um what do you think is going to happen? Gives you an error?
嗯，IOTA，我不那样认为，IOTA 正在接受，我认为，IOTA 正在生成序列 1, 2, 3。但是你必须把什么传给它才能让它生成那个？哦，比如 3？完全正确。哦，有趣。所以 APL 有逆扫描。它有逆 iota。对。
Gives you two, maybe? Gives you an error at the main arrow. Because it's not a valid IOTA sequence. So I could imagine cases where that would be useful. Like, if you wanted to check that people weren't plugging IOTA sequences into your unit tests because you wanted actual check that people weren't plug if you wanted to check that people weren't plugging
但这很有趣。它给你的结果是一个标量。我想这说得通。我的意思是，在我看来，这似乎是一个相当无用的算法，除了用来检查你是否有一个从 1 开始的单调递增序列之外，你还能把逆 iota 用在什么地方？如果，如果你给它 1 2 4 2 会发生什么？你觉得会发生什么？给你一个错误？
iota sequences into your unit tests because you wanted actual real data you know could be a useful algorithm yep it's but yeah no it's not super useful it's pretty awesome though they we've got so any basically any verb not all of them a lot of of them don't work, but if you can think of a reasonable inverse for a function that you have, it typically is there, which is super awesome. Should ranges have a, should we have a range adapter that inverses, that inverts an algorithm? Would that even make, no, that, I don't know if that would work, but should we have some CPO that inverts another CPO?
也许给你 2？在主箭头处给你一个错误。因为这不是一个有效的 IOTA 序列。所以我可以想象在某些情况下这会很有用。比如，如果你想检查人们是否没有把 IOTA 序列塞进你的单元测试中，因为你想实际检查人们是否没有塞进……如果你想检查人们是否没有塞进
Oh, this has actually come up. We've talked about this before. We've talked about a flip operation. I don't know if we talked about it here, but I think either you and I have talked about it or Christabella and I. It exists in Boost HANA, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah. I think either you and I or Christabella. No, I think it's been you and I who have talked HANA, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah. I think either you and I or Chris DiBella. No, I think it's been you and I who have talked about it, right?
IOTA 序列到你的单元测试中，因为你想要真正的真实数据，你知道，这可能是一个有用的算法。是的，这……但，是的，它不是超级有用。不过它挺酷的。我们有，所以基本上任何动词——不是全部，很多都不起作用——但如果你能为你拥有的函数想出一个合理的逆函数，它通常都在那里，这超级棒。Ranges 应该有一个吗？我们应该有一个可以求逆、对算法求逆的 range 适配器吗？那甚至会有意义吗？不，那，我不知道这是否行得通，但我们是否应该有一些 CPO 来求逆另一个 CPO？
Because didn't you want Flip for some? Oh, yeah, yeah. I go on and on about Flip. It's the C combinator, a.k.a. Cardinal, the Cardinal bird. But if we're going to have Flip, then shouldn't we also have Invert? I mean, Invert is not a combinator invert is just right a cool operator that that takes a function the way i imagine it works in apl just based on those examples you showed it's not something where it's a generic algorithm right like it's something where that
哦，这其实已经被提出来了。我们以前讨论过这个。我们讨论过一种 flip 操作。我不知道我们是不是在这里讨论的，但我认为要么是你和我讨论过，要么是克里斯塔贝拉（Christabella）和我。它存在于 Boost HANA 中，对吧？对，对，对。我想要么是你和我，要么是克里斯·迪贝拉（Chris DiBella）。不，我想是你和我讨论过它，对吧？
like iota no like it's not some generic thing that like takes iota and knows how to invert it like that's like some special wiring of logic that says hey like here's how you invert an iota yeah so i i think for the the verbs or functions like where inverse and scan those do have like a table look up where it's like oh if it's if it's a scan, this is the behavior or whatever. However, that being said, I do know that if you build up a point-free or tacit expression that consists purely of... A what? Like if you build up a tacit expression or point-free, which means that it doesn't mention its arguments.
因为你不是想要某种 Flip 吗？哦，对，对。我一直在喋喋不休地讲 Flip。它是 C 组合子，又名 Cardinal（红衣主教鸟）。但是如果我们要有 Flip，那我们难道不也应该有 Invert 吗？我的意思是，Invert 不是一个组合子，Invert 只是，对吧，一个酷炫的运算符，它接受一个函数——根据你展示的那些例子，我能想象它在 APL 中的工作方式——它不是那种通用算法的东西，对吧？就像是那种
Like you used some words there and then you like glided over them in your explanation. Yeah, continue. But if you... So my understanding is that there's some sort of i don't know what the algorithm is like recursive descent or something like that but like a composition of uh functions that all have inverses can also be inverted um yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that i i'm sure that there's some generic form like but but there's probably cases where the generic form falls apart. There's probably cases where there are invertible algorithms that you, the user, could write, but that you would have to somehow customize APL's inversion operation to explain, like imagine that IOTA was not a part of the core of APL.
像 iota 一样——不，它不是那种接受 iota 并知道如何将其求逆的通用东西——那就像是一些特殊的逻辑连线，说：“嘿，这就是你如何将 iota 求逆的方法。”对，所以对于像 inverse 和 scan 这样的动词或函数，它们确实有类似表查找的东西，比如“哦，如果是 scan，这就是它的行为”等等。然而，话虽如此，我确实知道，如果你构建了一个纯粹由……一个什么？由无参数表达式（tacit expression）或 point-free 组成的表达式，这意味着它不提及它的参数。
And you wanted to write your own IOTA. You'd probably have to express to it in some way how that inversion would work. So this is at the limits of my knowledge, but that is exactly what is possible in J. So in J, I believe they have an operator called obverse. Why it's called that, I'm not sure. But obverse enables you to define the inverse of a user-defined function, if my understanding is correct, which is pretty dope. So maybe that's a thing that we should have in C++.
就像你在那里用了一些词，然后你在解释中一笔带过了它们。对，继续。但是如果你……所以我的理解是，某种程度上，我不知道这个算法是什么，是递归下降还是别的什么，但像所有都有逆函数的函数的组合也可以被求逆，对吧，对，对，对，我确信存在某种通用形式，但是，但是可能存在通用形式崩溃的情况。可能存在一些可逆的算法，你（作为用户）可以编写，但你必须以某种方式定制 APL 的求逆操作来解释它们，想象一下 IOTA 不是 APL 核心的一部分，
We should have... Ladies and gents, look at that. J, APL, the array languages, they're coming to C++. This is the first step. You act as if I can just unilaterally decide what C++ does. I mean, you are chair of LOOG, right? Isn't that like half the reason of this podcast is so that I can slowly warp your mind until, I don't know about this proposal, it doesn becomes clear to me that the chair is more a servant of the participants than one might imagine. Well, that sounds like a good place to end it.
而你想编写你自己的 IOTA。你可能必须以某种方式向它表达那个求逆是如何工作的。所以这是在我知识的极限边缘，但这正是 J 语言中可能做到的。所以在 J 语言中，我相信他们有一个叫做 obverse 的运算符。为什么叫这个名字，我不确定。但 obverse 使你能够定义用户自定义函数的逆函数，如果我的理解正确的话，这相当厉害。所以也许这也是我们应该在 C++ 中拥有的东西。
Well, or let me put it another way. When your chair, your job is no longer to individually contribute. Your job is to help make sure that everybody else's individual contributions get a fair hearing and move ahead in a timely fashion. A moderator. Yeah. Yeah, a fancy moderator yeah and i some somebody just told me that it's not actually required for me to move to new york to take over titus's role as library evolution uh chair i assumed that there was some throne that i had to go and and take from him but uh
女士们先生们，看看这个。J、APL，这些数组语言，它们正在进入 C++。这是第一步。你表现得好像我可以单方面决定 C++ 做什么一样。我的意思是，你是 Evolution 工作组（LEWG）的主席，对吧？这难道不是这个播客的一半原因吗？这样我就可以慢慢扭曲你的思想，直到……我不确定这个提案，对我来说变得很清楚，主席更多是参与者们的公仆，而不是人们想象的那样。好吧，这听起来是个结束的好地方。
but not so much thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好吧，或者让我换个方式说。当你成为主席时，你的工作不再是独自做出贡献。你的工作是帮助确保其他所有人的个人贡献都能得到公平的听取并按时推进。一个主持人。对。对，一个花哨的主持人。对，而且我……刚刚有人告诉我，我其实不需要搬到纽约去接替泰蒂斯（Titus）担任库演进主席的职位。我以为那里有个王座，我得去从他手里夺过来，但是……